enfin bon je dis qu'est-ce qu'il faut il
faut trois ingrédients à un bon concept
des bons candidats aient un bon
animateur évidemment bien sûr alors
cette semaine en focus groups j'ai été
voir des gens et je leur ai posé les
questions des animateurs de jeux télé
c'est assez surprenant vous vous êtes
mis dedans pas non mais elle manque de
peu qu'elle je t'aimais bien fait je lui
emma bonjour déjà aujourd'hui on va
parler de jeux télé d'accord je vais
vous montrer des gens déjà vous allez me
dire si vous le connaissez la corrège
vous posera des questions d'accord va
bien et est ce que vous les connaissez
laurence boccolini ont collé dit j'aime
bien laurence vocaux d'amy jamais sa
présence j'ai aimé la manière dont tel
travail dont elle présente les jeux mais
khaled est candidat j'aime bien sa façon
de travailler
l'actrice a pas l'air d'accord du tout
non et votre opinion j'ai la mienne
voilà on est même attention là c'est
ligue des champions vous êtes prêts
désolé j'ai pris un traitement pour mon
épaule j'ai oublié les noms d'accord
maggie jean louis jean luc reichmann et
nagui je suis plusieurs jean-luc jamais
là quand vous dites ça
[Musique]
c'est jean luc gennart garde mes lèvres
pendant la nuit
c'est de m'embrouiller pour pas moi
jean-luc jean-luc ouais alors on
continue cela c'est laurence quoi ouais
laurent comment cabrol quoi laurent
cabrol et j'ai oublié la lettre sans
labour 10 langues avec les oui oui oui
pensez vous êtes et rotulien le père
havas voilà oui si vous deviez confié un
je vous confie riez acquis mais à droite
parce qu'il veut pas jeter paris fait
plus un peu plus intellectuel en premier
de la classe qui secrétaire d'état le
secrétaire d'état mme ça commence à
faire effet jean michel mr et il est
ministre
j'espère pas c'est un animateur on sait
pas donc de nouveaux clients j'espère
que vous les connaissez un petit peu
alors comme il chérit quelque chose qui
s'appelle thierry mais je connais pas
mais se plaint jamais pourquoi je crois
de cadrer leur nom de famille tu as
raison 80 pourquoi on s'en remettra les
ondes ça suffit terrible c'était réclamé
à paris j'ai aussi un jeu avec des
boules effet avec les bolt ça
dit comme ça c'est que ces visas entre
les deux votre coeur balance
mathieu parce que j'aime bien quand il
fait sa petite folle voilà c'est comme
ça depuis je vais lui pour viol et on
lui confierait quoi comme jeu de
l'ormeau il pourrait prendre la place à
thierry beccaro pour faire un jeu de
boules est ce qu'il ya un sous-entendu
où j'ai rêvé avant moi c'était vous ne
posez la question je vous réponde à mort
ajouté teddy et ben merci beaucoup
d'intellectuels que notre avait des
besoins du focus et mathieu vous aviez
un grand sourire au départ moi ce qui me
connaissent et puis la première fois en
trois semaines que j'étais gay vous
connaît oui voilà
mais à quel prix c'est trop comment à
mana sexualité quand même dommage que
maintenant c'est pas faux votre surnom à
mykonos non elle est maire d'aller à la
base je remercie ceux qui ont participé
lors à 20 son fils georges finale
[Applaudissements]